regresamos en directo y sean bienvenidos
a este especial de cultura para
conversar sobre la gala de los premios
oscar número 93 que tuvo lugar anoche en
los ángeles se premio lo mejor del cine
según la academia y pese a un año de
pandemia que frenó muchos estrenos hubo
variadas para ver lo que nos queda es el
sabor amargo de no haber podido llenar
los teatros para ver los nominados en la
pantalla grande pero esperemos que
pronto sea y en el estudio conmigo está
la experta en la materia de yanira gómez
en nuestra periodista cultural en france
yanira tiene la palabra para contarnos a
colores cómo fue la noche de la
ceremonia que no tuvo una asistencia
masiva y que además fue en una estación
de trenes pero en la que sí se logró por
fin reunir a las estrellas del cine cuál
fue este año el rasgo particular que
tuvieron los premios pues voy a empezar
a angela si me de si me permitís con la
esencia de estos premios es decir no
hemos podido ir a esos cines la pandemia
ha imposibilitado una mayor cosecha
cinematográfica pero eso no ha hecho que
los premios fueran de menor calidad no
al contrario ha permitido que este año
podamos decir que ha sido un año indie
del independiente del cine
por lo cual no siempre se puede quedar
opacado va a veces por lo comercial es
decir el barça de este extraño indi en
lo que se ha permitido es una apertura
una diversidad digamos inédita no
siempre esa crítica eso de óscar
software oscar tan blancos pues este año
hemos visto películas que teherán
la sensación socializadas perdón con un
montón de actores afroamericanos al
menos ocho grandes largometrajes tenía
no esta esencia por otro lado también ha
sido como un pequeño homenaje de nuevo
en otras para site a lo asiático a
partir de la gran ganadora que ahora
veremos y también ha sido como una
especie de espejo para eeuu no que eeuu
estamos pensando hoy desde el hollywood
de los años 30 hasta figuras de black
panthers hasta las consecuencias de la
crisis económica el sueño de ser
migrante el sueño americano entonces
hemos tenido como esta esencia además de
una gran apertura también para nuevos
directores no han estado los de siempre
no david fincher y aaron sorkin pero
también ha habido cabida para aquellos
que han tenido óperas primas y han sido
más
como podemos ver así a simple vista de
esa premiación no pues obviamente no mad
land ha sido la gran triunfadora junto a
man que también son dos metal que se han
llevado dos premios no en la gran
ganadora ha sido con tres premios y
también the father en judas on the black
mesa ya ha sido como los grandes
triunfadores hacia ojo de alcón es una
pantalla grande o el cuadro grande de lo
que fueron los premios ya vamos a ir los
desmenuzando premio por premio y yo le
diría a yanira que definitivamente lo
que se hizo este año fue pagar deudas
con lo que es la diversidad y lo que
debe verse en la pantalla y un rasgo muy
interesante es que los novatos
triunfaron cuéntenos precisamente es lo
que te decía no desde que hemos visto
estos ganadores así brevemente que ahora
los desmenuzar hemos pues han sido que
florián seller por ejemplo en ver al
final
darjus margen son nombres que no suelen
estar ahí no esto en una gala que hemos
visto que han tenido un ambiente are the
call que intentaba como tener corazón
por los premios en un año en el que no
hemos podido ver a los cines como
decíamos pero los productores encargados
con steven sobre a la cabeza
no han triunfado en ese querer tener
unos premios renovados y que fueran como
una película ha sido un completo fracaso
en ese sentido esta gala de los oscar y
de hecho también lo único que ha tenido
de película fueron unos créditos
iniciales pero si no fue todo el
anticlímax cerrando por ejemplo con un
premio anthony hopkins que no estaba no
estamos nosotros aquí con la resaca de
los premios oscar y también lo está
nuestro corresponsal en los ángeles a
anthony belchí quien nos envió todos los
detalles de cómo se logró esta gala en
pandemia
si la ceremonia de los premios oscar se
realizó en unas condiciones atípicas a
raíz de la crisis sanitaria por el
coronavirus y será por eso que esta
edición número 93 pasará a la historia
por haberse celebrado en medio de la
pandemia pese a las circunstancias
la academia quería exhibir total
normalidad en la gala y desde un
principio ya se dijo que iba a ser
completamente presencial de hecho los
organizadores prohibieron expresamente
las apariciones por videoconferencia y
por ese motivo se pusieron todas las
facilidades para hacer lo posible para
empezar la ceremonia no se celebró en un
solo lugar el emblemático teatro dolby
donde siempre se realiza se reservó para
las actuaciones musicales y en la
estación central de los ángeles mucho
más espaciosa para asegurar la distancia
social se colocó una reducida alfombra
roja donde pasearon pocas celebridades y
fue ahí donde también se celebró la
parte central de la gala la organización
también puso dos sedes más en parís y en
londres para que los que no pudieran
viajar desde europa por las
restricciones se pudieran disfrutar
igualmente de la
ceremonia además a todos los asistentes
también se les permitió ir sin
mascarilla aunque la academia aclaró que
sólo era para cuando aparecieran frente
a las cámaras y confirmó que además
todos los invitados se habían hecho las
pruebas de el coronavirus antes de
entrar al recinto con todo el cine
volvió a ser el gran protagonista de la
noche de los oscar
vamos a entrar en materia de yanira
vamos a hablar de la principal ganadora
de la noche nada sorpresiva pero sí muy
representativa nada sorpresiva porque
obviamente desde la muestra de venecia
cuando se presentó ya ha acumulado unos
220 27 premios sin contar los oscar es
decir es algo titánico y cuando uno
carga con este peso de ser favorita a
veces no se sale indemne pero en este
caso ha conseguido esa merecida no esa
merecida estatuilla porque en esencia
tiene una gran ética y una gran estética
podríamos decir para comentar estos
premios angela me gustaría empezar por
francis macdorman que fue ella además de
pues como sabemos son no más planes la
película elegida pero ella fue la
elegida como actriz principal me
gustaría empezar por ella porque al
final fue ella quien iluminó esa primera
chispa para que surgieran o matt la no
fue ella quien fue a buscar a la
directora club y chau y la quiso que no
al frente de este proyecto comprando
incluso los derechos del libro en el que
se basa entonces
francés mcdormand con esta gala pues que
ya podemos decir que se ha alzado con su
tercera estatuilla atrás
y el largo título de freak billboard que
hablábamos ahora pero además tiene un
cuarto premio porque es productora de
esta cinta entonces ha llevado dos
estatuillas
como tema muy resumido sin querer cargar
a la audiencia más hablando de los de
los colores que tiene esta película es
una mujer que en el año pues en contexto
de crisis económica pierde todo pierde a
su marido también pierde su lugar de
origen porque la empresa de nevada en la
que se encuentra en la que habitan
cierran por la crisis económica no y se
queda sin empleo y además de viuda no
entonces todo este es drama nos permite
hablar de una road-movie y con un toque
un poco de western por el país por un
eeuu que se abre en canal por sus
digamos
sus problemas como decíamos de este
reflejo no que se están mirando eeuu a
nivel laboral a nivel de sueños rotos
pero también hay un viaje por nuestra
propia humanidad no que quiero decir con
esto pues vemos la cultura nómada como
una alternativa de vida muy digna pero
también una reflexión existencial de
aceptación y empatía
y todo esto con un énfasis en el poder
de la comunidad cuando estos nómadas se
unen pero también con estas cosas
sencillas de la vida y ahí francis como
fer como personaje pues ha dicho no ha
llegado a decir hemos hecho una película
sobre diferencias económicas en eeuu
pero va mucho más allá no con esta
estética de documental como podemos ver
hay una gran fotografía de la pareja
precisamente de claudia o lo que tenemos
es una película que con unos personajes
que son de reales no porque también
ellos se han basado como vemos ellas han
sido quienes se han adentrado en este
mundo y si me permite meterme también
una película con una marca de mujer de
principio a fin y eso este año es muy
representativo exacto ahora lo veremos
con el guión original con emera al final
no pero para ir cerrando esta idea de
por qué no mad land se ha llevado este
está gran premio no pesa que teníamos
últimas dudas en la gala es por eso no
porque enferme en francés mcdormand
recae todo este peso d
ella escucha más que habla pero la
importancia es todo lo demás ese paisaje
y esos protagonistas que son reales que
son nom al dance de verdad como podemos
ver en el siguiente tráiler esa esencia
[Música]
sí
de nuevo
un señor k
parece que mcdormand lo tuviera todo
claro y que nunca lo hiciera nada mal
una actuación que sigue siendo tan
fabulosa como fue el 2017 su premio por
tres anuncios y un crimen
y bueno vamos a seguir avanzando a
través del corazón de esta gala sigamos
hablando de mujeres con la segunda
ganadora a mejor directora en la
historia de los premios este año además
de chloe fue histórico en general para
las mujeres en otras nominaciones exacto
angela pues de aquí concretamos
simplemente como dices nuevo histórico
por segunda mujer en 93 años de los
oscar sólo había habido una ganadora que
fue katherine bigelow por the hurt
locker en 2010 bueno es algo obviamente
el sorpresivo histórico y aquí
simplemente anotar que también se ha
planteado si hay una concesión asiática
por este premio el premio es merecido a
eso que quede claro pero si por ejemplo
china hoy en esta jornada después de
real de la resaca no el portavoz del
ministerio de asuntos exteriores ha
tenido que puntualizar que no que no es
algo es algo diplomático esta relación
con la película porque por ejemplo ha
tenido que suspender algunos
y publicaciones en redes sociales
entonces bueno es algo histórico y
barral con este lado asiático que
también los óscar pretenden reivindicar
que está en esta diversidad y como
decías pues aparte de esta directora
segunda mujer está en verdad final en
guión original por promising jon woman
en esta cinta como ella puntualizó en la
gala se hizo durante 23 días y es la
primera mujer en ganar en 13 años en
esta categoría en esta categoría de
guión original y por supuesto como tú
decías la academia no ha dejado pasar
esa oportunidad con la historia de tener
a un lado una directora y una gran
película de mujer y también este guión
original creado por x m la que además
más que oportunidad yo diría que es una
necesidad y que nuevamente me refiero a
que es una deuda que tiene la academia
con las mujeres que además de talento es
lo que hay y también que sorprende mucho
promise y nyon woman porque no es el
tipo de películas que uno típicamente
vería en una gala y cada ciertos años se
cuela una historia como ésta que además
está muy interesante para ver
precisamente dentro de este universo
para que podamos situarnos que
representa promise in your woman en unos
hollywood no es como dices es una
historia que puntualizamos no es de
venganza sino digamos que la venganza es
una catarsis no es el final o la causa
no es algo mucho más allá de eso y es
una denuncia de una realidad de toda la
vida existe el acoso lo vemos por todas
partes tanto que en la película
únicamente una vez se pronuncia la
palabra ruiz como para decir nosotros
entendemos todo ese universo de casey en
el que ha perdido una amiga debido a un
bueno no quiero hacer spoiler pero
digamos que ella no puede soportar el
dolor que supone haber sido agredida y
violentada no por un grupo tipo manada
de tanto que tanto vemos en las noticias
y ella digamos que se lo toma se se toma
la justicia por su cuenta no a falta de
autoridad es a falta de una sociedad que
sea consciente de todo esto ella se toma
la justicia por por su cuenta y
simplemente para
a poder dar ese mérito a merecen el para
que se entienda este mérito es decir que
hay una construcción de duelo la
película como te digo tiene un toque de
comedia negra no pero eso es todo es muy
importante entender que es merecido es
decir que cuando hablamos una directora
que hace un guión de sobre este tema de
acoso y abuso siempre se suele decir
como feminista pero no hay películas de
los años 90 como de clint eastwood en un
folk viven también trataban de un tema
si no estás main no hay qué encasillarlo
en que sea el año de las mujeres tampoco
porque si no el trabajo queda un poco
por el suelo por así decirlo vamos a
escuchar en este caso a emera pnv en él
y no es trabajo de una película juzgar o
tener un imperativo moral no
necesariamente algunos creen que si yo
no lo creo
yo quería hacer ante todo una película
divertida y con base en los personajes
porque quería hablar de ese
consentimiento y no sabía cómo
y si logra que sea más fácil esta
conversación entre hombres entre hombres
y mujeres y mujeres eso ya es
maravilloso en guangzhou pues mire ya
mira yo creo que esto es más fue
consecuencia natural de la necesidad y
sobre todo el derecho que tenemos las
mujeres de hacernos un espacio con él
mismo o incluso más talento a veces que
nuestros colegas hombres así que esto lo
que tiene que pasar es que va a seguirse
dando cada vez más en los premios oscar
hay que ver más presencia de mujeres y
bueno vamos a hablar de los demás
premios para los actores la categoría de
actrices no fue tan reñida como se
esperaba pero en cambio en la categoría
de actores era más bien previsible lo
que iba a pasar salvo una pequeña duda
que yo tenía con el chagüite bousman que
podíamos esperar pues por todo el tema
de su fallecimiento que se le diera un
premio
no fue así pero tampoco es nada
reprochable porque la actuación de the
father fue espectacular rescató última
cosa de promise in young woman como
decías dentro de muchísimos años una
década dos tres cuatro va a ser una gran
referencia precisamente por eso no
porque hoy en día podemos hablar de
estos temas y una mera fe en él puede
surgir de ahí no hemos visto actriz
principal actriz de reparto ha sido para
la coreada no vamos a decir deslenguada
porque es un personaje muy muy graciosa
a la vez muy clave en minar y el premio
fue para júnior yo y fue muy gracioso
porque en la gala hizo lo que todos
hubiésemos hecho al ver a brad pitt que
es decir donde estaba si eres productor
de minar y dónde estabas en el rodaje
encantada de conocerte de aguas y le
dijo y se ve un poco la esencia de esta
actriz con 40 años de carrera en corea
del sur muy conocida es se ha convertido
en la primera coreana y segunda asiática
en ganar el premio tras el de 1957 a la
japonesa miyuki unmequi como decimos es
alguien muy conocido en su país en
internacional y no tanto pero borda este
papel que tiene como de abuela
clave en el sentido de esta familia que
a diferencia de ubicarla en otro lugar
está en eeuu una familia inmigrante que
tiene el sueño en los 80 de poder
progresar no
y ella digamos que es esa pieza clave
entre el eeuu y corea del sur el
engranaje cómico también un poco duro a
veces no por sostener esa esta identidad
del grupo de hecho el niño de la
película que es un encanto le dice la
abuela huele a coreano entonces por este
lado sería el de actriz y como decías
por el lado masculino el de reparto del
actor de reparto para daniel kalu ya fue
algo bastante esperado también con esa
duda de por qué sí es casi protagonista
en judas and the black mestalla porque
hace parte de esta categoría y no la
otra ahora veremos porque como decías es
con anthony hopkins queríamos como la
academia creía cómo repartir ese
galardón
y finalmente no ha sido póstumo ha sido
para una figura como vemos en las
imágenes en la que daniel interpreta a
fred hampton que era el líder de los
black panthers en chicago versus tenía
un gran problema con el fbi de edgar
hoover y es eso lo que se trata más esa
figura de quien es el judas no es ese
otro integrante al que el fbi pues mete
dentro de la comunidad y en la querida
reivindicar muchísimo las figuras de
hampton dice también como diciendo
reivindicando que ayudó mucho a las
comunidades no finalmente tenemos a
anthony hopkins en un merecidísimo
premio como decías a sus 83 años se ha
convertido en esta categoría en el mayor
en conseguir la estatuilla y tenemos en
que hay que hablar aquí además de su
gran papel como ingeniero octogenario
que cuya mente cuya demencia senil hace
que toda esta película sea de género un
poco terror un poco a veces cómico un
poco drama sabe este es una mezcla
digamos que desde el punto de vista de
su mente él consigue eso carga con esa
con ese peso esa interpretación tan
fuerte y aquí puntualizamos por qué
34 florian ceder no ha conseguido este
triunfo para francia
y bueno
yo le agregaría yanira a todo este
resumen tan completo que nos está
haciendo la presencia muy importante y
muy destacada de olivia colman en esta
película la gran compañía que prestó
esta película con anthony hopkins que es
tan brillante como dura incluso hasta
deprimente pero también muy merecido muy
merecido este premio y por eso quisiera
que escucháramos las palabras de florian
heller y precisamente de anthony hopkins
pues tras conocer que ganaron el premio
los deseo de ser sino el deseo de hacer
esta película es indisociable el deseo
de hacerla con ego se olvidó un tipo
escribía el guión por él lo pensé por el
compartir esta alegría con él ha sido
muy significativo para mí
simón no tics a los 83 años no esperaba
recibir este premio
hoy se carne muy agradecido con la
academia and dragons page tribute sweet
child 2000 y quiero rendir homenaje a
chad big boats man nos lo arrebataron
demasiado pronto de nuevo gracias a
todos temas muy ciertas las palabras y
vamos a ver otras categorías diseño de
producción fotografía montaje sonido
maquillaje vestuario efectos especiales
estas personas que no tienen el
protagonismo y la visibilidad en
pantalla pero que hacen que la
experiencia sea simplemente mágica
yanira con mike empezando por mike con
diseño de producción y fotografía
fotografiaron a categoría un poco
disputada pero finalmente se ha ido para
eric messerschmidt y netflix también
podemos decir
y con este blanco y negro también ha
tenido la ambientación que vemos es muy
lograda del hollywood de los años 30 40
a partir del guionista de guionista
perdón con orson welles de men que vino
y la creación de steve thinking él ha
logrado que podamos transportarnos a ese
hollywood y también en pantalla con
detalles tan tan pequeñitos pero muy muy
significativos como por ejemplo ver el
granulado o las voces de escucharlas de
otro modo esta ha sido el premio para mí
en este sentido
en cuanto a sound of metal montaje y
sonido estaba muy claro era una de las
estatuillas más claras que había aunque
había dudas con soul solo que en la
historia de los oscar aquellas películas
que siempre han portado el nombre o de
algo sonoro era claro que tenía que ir
por ese lado exacto y siempre se han
llevado el premio entonces no había
mucha duda en cuanto a sound of metal
que es un montaje muy logrado del danés
mikkel nielsen y a la vez el sonido aquí
tenemos que reivindicar nuestra parte
latina porque hay unos mexicanos detrás
de de esta creación para que podamos
sentirnos de la piel digamos del
protagonista que acaba de perder y que
es un baterista además que vive del
sonido precisamente pues que pierde su
audición no y ellos lo que han creado a
partir de una cámara anecoica es simular
toda esta sensación dentro de la
película por último para ir acabando
margáin is black board con chadwick box
man como mencionaba si valió la davis ha
llevado el maquillaje y peluquería
principalmente porque lo que logra el
español sergio lópez ribera con mar con
mas reynish la cantante
plasmar ese rostro que echaba un poco
para atrás un poco duro pero también de
empoderamiento que ya tenía mientras que
el vestuario pues ha logrado arroz
también una veterana diseñadora que con
89 años ha conseguido esta estatuilla
finalmente tener ha conseguido como no
los efectos visuales no se ha sostenido
la oportunidad de verlo en gran pantalla
pero únicamente digamos más allá del
argumento de la historia lo que vale la
pena es ver a esos efectos que
curiosamente no son no tienen un gran
presencia en la película en el sentido
de que tiene menos de 300 tomas con
efectos digamos manipulados en
computador y el resto serían tomas
reales no a efectos prácticos como se le
suele llamar y eso es lo que le gusta a
christopher nolan y tampoco hay que
decirlo yanira están los clichés y
christopher nolan no se podía quedar sin
alguna premiación en estos oscar vamos a
conversar de la esencia de lo que fueron
estos trabajos muchos nos quedamos sin
el placer de ir a la pantalla grande a
verlos yo estoy haciendo mi lista para
tan pronto termine el aislamiento pero
usted nos puede
e ir contando y también podemos ir
viendo un poco de cada uno
steinmeier sales coches
[Música]
más cerca
yanira se quedó este año una danesa con
el premio mejor filme internacional y no
es la primera vez que ocurre de hecho es
bueno titulares en over round estaba
cantado pese a que hago una gran
recomendación a ver las otras películas
cuyos títulos son cubo vadis hay that
better days the man justo el skin y
collective que es un documental y son
buenísimas nosotros nos vamos a centrar
en 12 round que como todos los medios
han dicho y como él seguramente leerán
es una celebración de la vida porque la
premisa principal de esta película era
tratar la cultura del alcohol pero
ocurrió algo en la vida de stroman
thomas vinterberg que es que su hija
falleció días antes de empezar el rodaje
de la película que estaba muy pensada
para que estuvieran mclean y kelsang por
supuesto y esa idea cambió no no era
únicamente hablar del alcohol sino
ensalzar esa vitalidad no porque lo que
tenemos aquí es un grupo de cuatro
profesores que están hastiados de sus
vidas y al final tras una cena lo que
deciden experimentar es que es la teoría
básicamente de un psiquiatra noruego que
dice
en nuestra tasa de alcohol en un déficit
y ellos se intentan compensarlo para
poder alcanzar esa vitalidad obviamente
en el camino se pasa ocurren algunas
desgracias algunas alegrías obviamente
gracias a este experimento pero es sin
duda es esa celebración con un match
mikkelsen que él sostiene toda esa
actuación nada más que decir ahí
simplemente hay que verla y darles la
oportunidad a las demás de que
estuvieron en competencia y en el
siguiente tema tampoco hubo sorpresa
para la mejor película de animación
disney pixar de siempre tienen el
llamado primordial aunque aunque hay que
decirlo soul fue una muy muy buena
película solo es una muy buena película
pero dentro de si miramos estas
categorías esta categoría habían rasgos
interesantes por este lado asiático en
over the moon por ejemplo para
obviamente pixar se merecía este premio
por soul sobre todo por su música que
por supuesto es lo que ganó también en
banda sonora original pero debo decir
que también ahí estaba muy reñida golf
world walkers que es de una irlandesa de
de la productora de jartúm salud y que
también merecía digamos moralmente ese
empujón o por que pixar como veníamos
diciendo pues las grandes productoras
siempre están presentes en unos premios
como estos
entonces sí soul es una gran película de
animación también pretende ensalzar esta
vida con este personaje no que por fin
hacer spoiler de nuevo por cosas desde
su trayectoria de su infelicidad también
aprende la lección a entender esa vida
con un gran peso de la música como la
música nos rescata también de eso una
película de animación que no es para
niños es para todos y estamos de acuerdo
habría que darle espacio a otras
productoras no solamente a las grandes
casas de producción documental ya ni a
un documental ha sido la gran decepción
yo creo aunque es un gran documental my
octopus teacher es la no deseada digamos
la gran no deseada de esta gala porque
habían otros documentales muy potentes
como time precisamente con este lado más
afroamericano de revisarse en eeuu
en todo caso es una bonita historia de
pippa el rey y james red en el que hay
un gran vínculo entre alguien que
precisamente también está perdido en
esta en su vida pero el hecho de ir a
frente a su casa
de zambullirse y el haber encontrado una
compañía que es un pulpo no es que suena
raro sigue aparejado poco usual en el
cine muy poco usual exacto pero tiene
mucho sentimiento y es increíble como
nuestra relación con la naturaleza
muchas veces no está planteada no en
este tipo de gala de oscars otros
premios bueno ya pues estamos llegando
ya al final de este especial es un
completo resumen de lo que teníamos este
año en la gala de los oscar como dije al
principio nos quedamos con las ganas de
verlas en pantalla grande y aquí yo
quiero rescatar el comentario de frances
mcdormand en cuanto ganó el premio a
mejor actriz y ella lo que dice es que
esta no sea una oportunidad para
calificar lo mejor o lo peor sino para
que todos después vayan y vean en todas
las películas que estuvieron nominadas
esta noche y creo que eso es lo que hay
que hacer apoyo
a la cultura y revivir toda esta
industria que está dando pasos todavía
de bebé para el cierre los queremos
dejar con la ganadora mejore de canción
original de la cantante here fight for
you y de la película judas and the black
mensaje
[Música]
ya ves
[Aplausos]
la recomendación es saber completa
completa las canciones si es que no lo
han hecho ya a nuestros televidentes
apenas ha pasado una noche desde que
conocimos los ganadores de estos dos
oscar y todos tenemos lista en mano para
ver las que nos faltaron yanira su
conclusión cuál fue sus sensaciones
después de haber visto esta premiación
esta premiación lo podemos decir alto y
claro fue terrible es decir no busquen
ver la gala de nuevo porque realmente la
esencia de estos premios se quedan en
las películas propuestas algunos dirán
que a lo mejor no había títulos muy
fuertes este año pero yo creo que ha
sido más un año de oportunidad que en la
gala no se consiguió no el querer hacer
una gala distinta para remontar
audiencia eso no se consiguió pero al
menos hubo títulos que yo creo que
apelaron mucho a la escencia el momento
justo no casualidad de que nos
encontremos en una pandemia pero apelan
más al pensarse a sí mismo y que por
ejemplo cómo no mad line para rescatar
la gran ganadora como decía francis
macdorman no es tanto lo que tenemos
materialmente sino lo que tenemos dentro
como como tesoro mientras que club y
chao apelaba a la
y creo que es eso y además de recomendar
buscar el resto de películas que son
maravillosas la verdad muy bonito
repensar lo que es nuestro hogar a
partir de no matar muchísimas gracias a
ustedes yanira y pues el otro año serán
nuevas películas al final lo que usted
dice de que la gala no estuvo tan buena
eso es accesorio lo importante son las
películas gracias por estar con nosotros
sigan en france 24
y